[Music]
metroid is a nintendo institution one
that dates back almost as far as the
company's console business but it's been
in a funk for the past decade and losing
favor along the way fans don't want
experimental spin-offs like Metroid
Prime Federation force they want to
explore creepy alien worlds as Samus
Aran and hunt for secret and high-tech
equipment
finally with Metroid Samus returns that
call has been answered
now why it took Nintendo's so long to
get to this point is anyone's guess but
Samus Returns is so good that it almost
doesn't matter a reimagining of the
offline Game Boy game Metroid to the
return of Samus Samus Returns is classic
Metroid at heart as in the 1991
monochromatic classic you hunt down
dozens of powerful Metroid's on planet
sr388 in an effort to eradicate the
bioweapon species and keep them out of
Evil's hands however two key changes
have occurred the map on the planet has
been greatly expanded and reshaped to
more closely resemble what you might
find in Super Metroid and combat is more
of a priority than ever
the latter is an effect of Nintendo
bringing on Mercury's team to develop
the game thankfully and most importantly
Sheamus returns feels like a Nintendo
made Metroid but it's still easy to spot
mercury seems influenced for the better
the most immediate contribution that you
see is samus's new parry action a first
for the series that allows you to
counter-attack and stun a rushing
opponent in turn common enemies mostly
alien wildlife are more aggressive than
usual more liable to seek you out than
wait for you to make the first move
though appearing feels a bit strange at
first as it brings your momentum to a
temporary halt you quickly learn the
proper timing and understand how it fits
into your repertoire and win to rely on
it you can also fire in any direction
now thanks to the 3d S's analog stick
all you need to do when surrounded by
enemies is hold another button to stand
your ground and aim freely samus's
newfound flexibility and physicality
makes her feel like an even more capable
hero and makes the moment-to-moment
exploration more lively than usual
considering that metroid is more or less
the foundation of so-called Metroidvania
games where you wander massive
environments poking and prodding walls
and ceilings to reveal secret chambers
and items it's both curious and exciting
when you unlock samus's scanned pulse
ability triggering a pulse both reveals
map layouts and information including
hidden passages and temporarily
highlights breakable objects in your
environment you no longer need to waste
time looking for secrets that may not
exist
conversely Samus Returns makes the
process of acquiring items you've
located more difficult than usual
you're now challenged to quickly juggle
weapons abilities and maneuvers without
faltering to reach items picked up
during your scans there's a healthy
balance between easy pickups and these
more puzzling scenarios and compared to
other 2d metroids it's far more
fulfilling to work smarter rather than
harder to reach a hundred percent item
completion the real metroid endgame
[Music]
by and large Samus returns does a great
job of providing insight into samus's
ever growing capabilities giving you the
information you need to overcome most
puzzles or obstacles there is however
one isolated blemish in this regard a
maneuver with inconsistent behavior
depending on a very specific
circumstance that's never mentioned or
hinted at whether by design or by
accident this exception flies in the
face of the game's otherwise clear and
informative nature and proves
frustrating in a few specific and
punishing locations upgrades aside the
all-important Metroid battles are the
other star of the show and you will
encounter over 40 of them during your
mission at varying stages of the species
evolution you initially battle with
alpha Metroid's the first step beyond
the familiar jellyfish form without
advanced weapons and defenses at the
start you will still struggle a little
while they dive bomb you from overhead
but they're always exposed weak points
do make them easy targets the next few
evolutions are notably more powerful
capped off with omega Metroid's towering
quadrupedal beasts that quickly climb
walls and spew damaging fireballs
granted why these bosses are more
involved and enjoyable than fighting
common enemies there comes a time when
facing even omegas stops being really
excited but Samus returns has some
tricks up its sleeve
introducing a few surprise battles that
help break up the action overall and
subtly reinforce Metroid two's critical
link to the rest of the series
samus returns story and lore will
resonate with anyone who's familiar with
chozo the origin of Metroid's and samus
his role in the future for anyone else
the implications therein will likely fly
over their heads
but smartly mercury steam in intend o
have elegantly incorporated these
details so as to not distract an
uninterested player Samus returns is at
its best when you are engaged in
exploration in common and thus sink
deeper into the planet and into
isolation these are things anyone can
joy and the game never lets teasing and
pleasing fans getting away as the first
2d Metroid game in over a decade
samus returns faces unfairly high
expectations in hindsight there was
never anything to worry about
and a lot to look forward to Sheamus
Returns is both a return to form and a
look to the potential future for 2d
Metroid games where combat plays a
bigger role and exploration involves
clever thinking rather than persistent
guessing fans get more than they
bargained for and everyone else gets a
great 2d action game with one of the
most captivating and capable video game
heroes around
[Music]
[Applause]